let's talk about how to get rid of
cellulite the cottage cheese-like
appearance that you don't want on your
body
i did a video on this a while ago but i
wanted to update it because i have some
new information that you're going to be
excited about now just realize there are
things you can do that will create a
significant difference in cellulite
sometimes
people will tell you there's nothing you
can do so just live with it don't buy
into that on that note in order to fix a
problem we have to really understand the
problem the more we understand it the
easier it is to fix it and when people
talk about cellulite there are
so many different theories so many
different treatments
so many different
viewpoints okay
but i found some great fascinating data
in a patent which i'm going to put the
link down below and the cool thing about
a patent is they organize all the
research on cellulite for you so that
gives you a head start so you have
something to work off of here's some
information that will kind of give you a
little foundation before i get into what
to do
cellulite only occurs in the butt
thighs and hip it does not occur in the
breast arm or your stomach okay now
what's interesting about that is that
in this area of the body
there are twice as many alpha-2
receptors now what is an alpha-2
receptor an alpha-2 receptor is in the
fat cell and it tells the body to store
fat for
later
use okay and so one of the big purposes
of this fat
around this lower part of the body is to
act as a reserve for pregnancy
okay in lean times so this fat can
actually provide fuel for the baby if
someone's pregnant
so what else do we know we know that
cellulite gets worse
with pregnancies okay it gets worse when
you take
hormone replacement therapy it gets
worse when you take birth control pills
it gets worse with
menopause
so
normally okay right underneath the skin
you have this
very structured organized
connective tissue like a fishnet that
holds everything real nice and organized
and very very tight so that way we have
this nice smooth layer of skin on the
outside
and then we have the fat layer and then
we have the muscle right underneath it
that's in a normal situation with
cellulite
the bands the collagen bands are
partially
or completely
dissolved
and that is some new information that i
recently found out about okay so what's
happening is you're getting this loss of
this fibrous fishnet that's supposed to
hold these fat cells really nice and
organized and they are basically all
chaotic and they're pushing up against
the skin now because there's nothing to
hold them in place and they're creating
this dimple cottage cheese like
appearance
you also have an enlarged fat cell
you have usually thin skin
we have circulation loss sometimes we
have fluid retention sometimes we have a
backup of the lymphatic system and we
usually always have atrophy of the
muscles underneath so it's a combination
of quite a few things but the question
is
why
what is causing this loss of this
collagen well this is not a fat problem
this is a collagen disorder caused by
excess estrogen okay
now wait a second how can it be excess
estrogen if if someone has menopause
well during menopause
you have a loss of ovary function and
what a lot of people don't know is you
have other parts of your body that also
make estrogen like your fat cells
like your skin cells they actually make
estrogen and the way that they make it
is through an enzyme called aromatase
so what aromatase does
right underneath the skin
and in the fat cell
is it converts testosterone
into
estrogen so it's going to get this extra
estrogen
from
the testosterone and
probably what's happening and there's
this compensatory or compensating
mechanism when there's lower estrogen to
then make more
in various places and so we have two
things going on we have this excess
estrogen that destroys collagen fibers
and elastin okay if there's too much if
there's just a right amount it's not
going to destroy anything but if there's
too much it's going to be a problem
and if there's excess aromatase
that is going to destroy the fibroblasts
that make the collagen underneath the
skin and so you're going to end up with
like virtually nothing to hold this fat
in place and that is the
jiggly kind of fat that
that people just want to get rid of and
so they get in a diet they start losing
fat and it just never gets rid of the
cellulite because it's not a fat problem
and it's not even necessarily
a diet problem directly even though that
is involved indirectly
it's really a hormonal problem mainly to
do with estrogen but there's other
hormones involved too
like cortisol because the cortisol is
going to create the atrophy of the
muscle
like a loss of growth hormone as you age
that's the main fat burning hormone
like insulin which if you have too much
insulin that's going to block any chance
of
losing fat which now this enlarged fat
cell never is able to go away so we want
to reduce insulin and then melatonin not
just for your sleep
for your antioxidants there's a lot of
interesting new information about
melatonin in another video that is very
interesting but the loss of melatonin
can create
a lot of issues related to cellulite as
well as just fat burning in general
and having a nice quality sleep and
preventing a lot of illnesses
and then we have dhea this is kind of
like a
a pre-hormone that will help you make
other hormones and usually as we age we
become deficient in this precursor and
so that could be another issue as well
all right so now that you have the
foundation let's go into a plan of what
you can do about it okay here's the plan
number one we have to fix the atrophy
problem how do we do that
we have to stimulate the muscles which
ones the glutes
the thighs
and the hip muscles there's some really
good exercises to isolate those muscles
doing lunges
squats
and also retro walking now what is that
that is walking backwards it's an
awesome exercise to stimulate the areas
where people have cellulite and you can
even do it on the treadmill if you do it
very gradually because if you do it too
fast you can hurt yourself so i'm going
to put links down below so you can learn
how to do each of these with the right
form
and do it correctly don't just jump and
start doing it i found some really good
videos relating to these three things
right here now as far as walking
backwards you can do this at a park um
just you know watch where you're going
okay and of course when you're treadmill
you start off like with one mile an hour
and you just gradually increase there's
another video i'm going to put down
below that shows you
a higher level
of doing this
it should only be done once you've
gotten pretty good shape but i found a
video that's just awesome that would
really work this whole area because what
we have to do is we have to stimulate
these muscles to cause
growth hormone to be activated and to
increase the muscle tone underneath this
whole thing that's going to help greatly
now i wanted to put number four for
certain people but not everyone because
this is pretty intense
i recently did a video on the
most powerful
high intensity interval training
exercise which is sprinting it's called
a hit exercise
this will produce the most fat burning
of anything the problem with it
you can't do it with
bad knees or a bad back you have to be
in pretty good shape to do this
and you have to go really really light
in other words if you overdo it you're
going to be sore for a long period of
time because you're doing this massively
intense workout with like a 100 effort
and you really can only go for a short
period of time in fact i only recommend
going for 10 seconds
just doing it two or three times max
maybe two times right because you're
going to feel so sore the next day
you're probably not going to get out of
bed like myself
where i did it a lot longer thinking
that i was 18 again and so i'm only 29
so i don't know why i can't handle it
but you can get very very sore with this
sprinting and
you're going to work muscles that you've
never ever worked before but it's very
very therapeutic maybe you're not going
to do a hardcore flat out sprint maybe
you just do it like at 50
all right so
you can watch these videos and start to
stimulate these muscles on a regular
basis okay
number two
you're going to fix the circulation
problem what happens with cellulite is
you lose the vascular
system right underneath the skin so we
get a lot of congestion we don't have a
lot of circulation we get a lot of free
radical damage and
and everything is kind of chaotic so
there's a couple things you can do to
increase blood flow to the area there
are several things you can do you can do
the rebound exercises okay
i have a video on that i will put that
down below
and you can also do red light therapy
they have these little wands that you
can rub on your skin now at first you're
thinking
that's not going to do anything but
there's some really powerful research
using infrared
light it's extremely therapeutic for
increasing melatonin okay if you haven't
seen my video on that i put that down
below too melatonin is one of the most
powerful antioxidants in your entire
body so it's going to protect the
mitochondria from all this free radical
damage so it's going to help you just
stay healthy and prevent the aging of
the skin and it's going to help you
sleep apparently the pineal gland is
really only a backup
to this other
melatonin in all the other cells in the
body which is stimulated by infrared
from the sun in other locations but you
can use the red light therapy to
increase melatonin some people are doing
it with the infrared saunas there's a
lot of different things you can do with
that so that's one thing you can do to
increase melatonin increase antioxidants
and increase your sleep which is going
to lower cortisol and help you recover
much better from this workout
doing a dry brush okay i did a video on
this where you're getting this brush and
you're rubbing the superficial part of
your skin to stimulate a reaction in
your skin to cause it some stress so it
can rebound and actually start to
improve circulation a lot of great data
on this i would highly recommend getting
a dry brush and stimulating the outside
of the skin which is going to affect the
inside of the skin right below the
surface
the other thing you can do
is to get a massage in this area down
here on a regular basis because what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
get more blood flow we're trying to get
more
lymph moving through the body the lymph
system is at the end of the circulatory
system so you have all the vascular
system that ends up in the capillaries
and then
it crosses over into the lymph system
okay and that it's a whole different
circulatory system and so when you do
like rebound exercises and you do red
light therapy dry brush massage these
are all really good to stimulate
circulation and as well as lymphatic
drainage
all right the next one fix the collagen
problem
how are we going to do that
well
there's a condition called autophagy and
that occurs when you do fasting
autophagy is a condition
that allows you to recycle old damaged
proteins as in
collagen scar tissue fibrous tissue
and not only does it break that down it
replaces it with new tissue so autophagy
is a condition
that is very rejuvenating it's
anti-aging and you want to start doing
fasting on a regular basis
not only that fasting will stimulate
growth hormone allow you to burn ketones
which is all very therapeutic to your
skin as well as help you lose the fat
directly so i would recommend doing
intermittent fasting on a regular basis
as well as
prolonged fasting
on more of a periodic basis i have a lot
of videos i'll put a link down below of
how you can get started
and then i'm going to recommend getting
an aromatase inhibitor
cream
okay
i'm not going to get into brands because
i don't want to
mention a brand and all of a sudden if
they change the formula then then you're
going to blame me the whole thing so
you're going to have to do your research
on that
you want to get aromatase inhibitor
cream you can get them on amazon you can
buy them from various health food stores
one is called dim okay
that's a concentrated cruciferous
version you don't want to get the pills
you want to get the topical version and
you want to rub it into your skin
okay each night before you go to bed
what is this going to do it's going to
help
reduce this aromatase which is creating
the damage so we can actually stop the
bleeding and we can actually start to
turn things around
so this is just one piece of data that i
found in that patent that was very
fascinating with all the research that
backs it up okay so mistakes that people
make going too fast okay when you're
exercising you can very easily overdo it
and then be completely sore uh for a
very long time so you want to go into it
very slowly when you start out
especially if you have atrophy all right
the next mistake is working out over
soreness so if you're sore don't keep
working out because the benefit of that
workout is to get sore and then recover
okay if you work out over soreness
you're basically damaging an already
damaged muscle all right the next point
is not creating enough stimulus for the
muscles so
if you're going too light and you're not
doing it enough
that's another problem so we want the
optimum amount of stimulus to the muscle
so you actually feel it and you get sore
and then you're going to let it heal so
we don't want to go too light and too
infrequent
the other point is your sleep if your
sleep is poor
then you're going to have a hard time
having this work out because the
cortisol is going to be very high the
insulin is going to be very high
because of the cortisol and that's one
point you really want to focus on but
the infrared
information can greatly help melatonin
and help you sleep
all right and last point
a big mistake is not giving enough time
thinking it's going to happen
in
a couple weeks
unfortunately you have probably years of
breakdown of this collagen this this
web-like fibrous net that's been
breaking down and it's going to take
some time it's going to take some months
and it could take even up to a year
maybe a year and a half but just realize
that you're going to improve the more
you do it but you just want to stick to
it to the point where you start seeing
change the problem is when you evaluate
yourself today versus tomorrow you see
nothing so the change is going to be so
gradual you you're going to think it's
not working so i highly recommend you
take pictures before and after maybe
once a month so you can visually see
that it is working all right if you
haven't seen my video on melatonin yet i
think that would be a perfect next video
to watch check it out right here